all right what's up mkbhd here welcome
to the first pc that i have built in i
have to look this up nine years so i've
made a lot of videos about computers and
we've had pre-built pcs in here but i've
never actually built one from scratch
since 2013 which if you look back was
actually a hackintosh but we don't talk
about that i'm gonna be doing this again
with a bunch of parts here and i have
decided i'm only going to be using
youtuber merch here to build it so i've
got the desk mat here mkbhd.com i've got
a knife because we've got some unboxings
to do this is the jerryrig everything
knife you've probably heard of it it's
pretty sweet it's actually the sharpest
knife i own and then we have this video
sponsor
yes actually the linus tech tips
screwdriver
both in the creator edition and the
regular edition but shout out to linus
and the team who have been working on
this for apparently three plus years to
put this together which is pretty sweet
so let's take a look at this one let's
unbox the screwdriver
oh we got the nice linus orange colors
in here so there it is
feels very solid and you've probably got
some
bits in here so it comes with all 12 of
these bits here and you can store all 12
of those bits up here in the top that's
really satisfying nice yeah this is made
in partnership with megapro tools who
has tons of experience making tools like
this and there's a magnet in the shaft
so if you have trouble like grabbing a
screw that should be no problem i'm
probably gonna use the phillips a lot
i'm just gonna preload that oh i forgot
to mention we are gonna be doing a quick
giveaway stay tuned to the end for a
little bit of details but
this
is a creator edition of the screwdriver
and the only thing that means for me
is it's red and black which is a special
little bit of a colorway so you got the
stealth matte black version and you've
got a red and black version i'm going to
give these away again
we'll talk about it at the end actually
for this video i'm going to build this
pc with the red screwdriver to be that
much more special it's so when i give it
away you'll have a 101 that built this
pc but if you want to get one of these
in the standard colors yourself you can
you can go to
lttstore.com and pre-order yours today
so i've got all the parts over here
let's just go through them one by one
[Music]
all right so first up we've got the case
this is corsair's 4000x it's a midtower
pc case and it's pretty simple it's 130
bucks it's got some fans in the front
tempered glass rectangle nothing crazy
it's just going to be a standard
high end pc build then next up i think
it's important to introduce the
motherboard and the cpu we're using this
is an asus pro art
z690 you can see a pretty sweet black
and gold box here which is using
intel's 12th gen chip here intel core i9
so we're going to pop that in there and
i'll go over all the details as we start
to install them but i'm just going to
give you the quick run through the
all-in-one liquid cooler for the cpu
it's corsair's h150i
it's got a bunch of fans and it's really
solid we'll get to that when we install
it then i also have here our ram 64 gigs
of ram
from g-skill and also a bunch of m.2
ssds they're very fast we've got two
four terabytes and two two terabytes yes
the board has enough to support it and
i'll install them all in front of your
very eyes and then last but not least
here
is
we'll get to that this is our power
supply so asus 1200 watt modular power
supply and a bunch of our cables here
modular power supply means of course
we're picking our cables and
our gpu might look a little bit
different as you can see that's an intel
arc a70 we've talked about nvidia and
amd in the past this is a little bit of
a different option
but i think we'll start
with the motherboard
this is our board this is asus's new pro
art motherboard this comes with three
months of adobe's creative cloud for
free so you can kind of get a sense of
who they're aiming at with this board
all right wow
it's got some heft to it it's a very
solid board i want to put together as
much of the computer as possible on the
board here in front of me before i try
to put it in the case so i'm going to
put the cpu in i'm going to put the ram
in i'm going to put the ssds in and
we'll see about the cooler how much i
can do before i actually have to start
cable managing and putting it in the
case all right so here is our
cpu this is intel's core i9 12900k i
haven't seen
cpu packaging in a while and this is
definitely
much fancier than i remember so that's
pretty cool twist to open this is the
fanciest
very nice
very nice i mean at the end of the day
it's a cpu and a plastic case but you
know this is nice presentation so i'm
gonna not even take it out yet but i'm
gonna open this
latch here
and this will
open
i'm going to line up
that arrow we see on the bottom corner
with the arrow that i saw here on the
bottom left corner
i'm just going to place that down
right there so then i'm going to push
this cover down
push this down
and our cover pops off
and our cpu is installed all right i'm
gonna do ram next i think the ram is
probably some of the best looking stuff
in the inside of a pc especially if it
has lights on it which this one does so
we've got two sticks of memory here
these are two
32 gig ddr5 memory sticks and you could
go
double it up in the future i only have
four slots on this board but that's fine
and i'm going to make sure i install
dual channel memory
in the appropriate slots on the board
here it's a good crunchy sound when you
do it right
beautiful we've got our ssds our
incredibly fast m2 ssds and on this
board we have our pci slots but then
under these we have our m2
ports i'm gonna just use a screwdriver
and pop these open what should i use
here i'm gonna go flat head
to unscrew these
so there's the first m2
slot if you told somebody in 2013 when i
last built the pc that you could get
a four terabyte drive
in the palm of your hand i would not
have believed you i would not have
believed you trying to tell me that is
four terabytes
those pins connected
they are seated cool and then i'm just
going to push this down
to the screw here
and then
use that
to lock it in place that's actually
super easy all right so we've got a
bunch more i actually don't need all
these drives but i'm going to install
some more
anyway
so this is the bottom this is the last
two
m2 pcie
4.0
slots
i assume they're next to each other
so actually what's interesting now is
these drives have their own heat sinks
in their little covers
as you can tell so my job now is to peel
off this cover and pop the heatsink back
on
and that'll be good for the drives i'm
going to take this move to the side and
start working on the case i'm going to
go power supply and then we'll go from
there i'm going to save
[Music]
this peel for when it's done that'll be
my reward so okay with the door off and
we can see what sort of a canvas
we have
to work with it's got three fans here
space for the power supply down here
this is a hard drive bracket but
we don't have hard drives in this build
we have literally terabytes of ssd
so
i think i should just be able to take
that out yeah matter of fact let's take
that out so let's come from the back
take this other panel off and make space
for the ss or for the uh power supply
but let's take this bracket out the way
oh thumb screws i was about to thought i
was gonna have to use a screwdriver
again actually
that's pretty tight there we go okay
[Music]
this is the part where it gets fun
because i it's been a long time like i
said since i've built a pc
power supply
yup solid metal all the rog stuff is so
consistently
rog like the rog phone
looks like the rog monitor which looks
like the rog power supply which looks
like the rog
graphics cards i mean these things are
consistent so as a modular power supply
it of course comes with a box of cables
i'm not going to be using any of these
but it does have
your main power cables and all that good
stuff but we're using some cable mod
cables as you already saw i also just
noticed this just like the rog phone
there is a screen
on this power supply but the thing about
this screen
and this case is it's going to be
sitting in there
blocked by the door so you're not
actually going to be able to see it but
that would just show you
i guess the amount of watts of power
you're drawing so here these are the
cables we're going to be using with this
power supply
cable mod
pro series cable kit
so the last time i built a pc i
definitely just used the included cables
with the modular power supply
these oh these look way better nice
and these are specifically matching
these are for this power supply which is
sweet there's a little air intake at the
bottom so we know the orientation
of the power supply in the case which
will be
like that
and then all the cables will come into
the case and be routed up the back
through here so
let's start by attaching them okay so
this is actually kind of nice it's
labeled right here so
these two are for the motherboard this
is gonna go here which means
this is gonna go
here
fan down
oriented correctly
let's line her up
all right so now that we've got the
cables
in the power supply power supply in the
case i'm just going to check to make
sure
all of our
parts fit
swivel this around
so you can check with me so the board's
obviously got its spot up here it's
going to be oriented
that way i'm also going to double check
this cpu cooler
which is pretty i don't know it's pretty
big we'll see if it fits in this case
and
hoping
oh
this is a three fan three times 120 it's
a 360 ml radiator this case is not
designed to fit those it'll only fit a
240 we're gonna get a little bit
creative with this one since there are
three fans in the front that's still big
enough for a 360. so i'm gonna replace
the three front fans
with
this radiator
should still work i'm gonna have to take
fans out take the front off it's a
little bit extra fun this is what pc
building is all about unfortunately
we'll have to put the tubes at the top
to get it to actually fit and connect
that's you're not supposed to do that
but i don't know ltt inspect this build
with this exact config so i'm gonna make
the best of it luckily i have my handy
ltt screwdriver which makes this all
super easy
so now i'm gonna put these fans
into this radiator typically don't want
to put the cables or the tubes at the
top
but we're making do with the parts we
have
so now next up i'm going to put this
back plate behind the motherboard which
is going to help us put the cpu cooler
on and then i'm going to put the
motherboard in the case
so i've got to line up all of these
spots
okay it's actually not too hard see this
is nice magnetic screwdriver holds onto
the screw pop into the corner
i wonder if anyone's ever built a pc and
it just went perfectly and our
motherboard is now seated so then our
next step here i've got it all
ready to put the cpu cooler on
the cpu
get another one to go
leave it there screw it in okay this is
the final major piece
which is the gpu this is the this is the
different one as you guys have probably
seen over the past few years
amd versus nvidia wars raging on as far
as discrete gpus and then when you see
an integrated gpu it's typically a good
intel one they're jumping in the game of
discrete gpus and this
is the arc a770
it's going to feel somewhere in the
range of an rtx 3060 or 3060 ti maybe
you can see the fans on the outside it's
matte black it's kind of a pretty simple
looking card if you ask me and i'm going
to be putting it right in this top pci
slot here and this is a this is the rgb
controller cable so i do have some pins
to get this guy to light up oh is that
the light right there probably there you
go oh all the way around nice
and it's a dual slot card so i'm going
to take the top two
out
that should do it so now i gotta line
these up and listen for the click
yep
[Music]
i like that there's a lot of matte black
going on in this build and it speaks to
me
and i'm very happy with that gotta plug
it in in fact we gotta do
a whole bunch
of cable management and cable plugging
in nobody really wants to watch me do
that so
with the magic
of video editing let's fast forward a
couple hours
all right
here we are as you can see
this is the finished build and spoiler
yeah i did go a little bit beyond that
plugged some things in booted it up for
the first time and got everything
working but i am happy to say
the pc works it's alive i do want to
deliver those last few peels that i
promised
[Music]
i'm pretty proud of the way the red and
black aesthetic turned out so here we
are now that it's fully booted i feel
like i i learned a lot both about
building a pc today in 2022 with all the
new and interesting parts we have here
how clean we're able to make it look
obviously having the m.2 ssds in here
keeps it looking particularly sparse
there's lots of clean open spaces
airflow moving through here but also
just remembering back in the other pcs
that i built which were for very
different purposes the hackintosh was
very much a hack like one of the things
i remember about it was we literally
couldn't turn it off or it might not
turn back on again like that type of
thing this is just an all-around
high-end fun great daily driver matter
of fact we got
forza on here already all right in the
controls i can change video settings to
1440p
[Music]
and on high
at
fps that should look
pretty good and now we're way up at
90 to 100 fps
so you guys might remember the we tried
some of this crazy forza demo at on 8k
on that machine on the super high-end
main gear this even at 1440p on high
settings which looks incredible i'm
pretty much locked at upper 80s lower
90s fps suffice to say this this intel
card can definitely handle some pretty
solid
gaming so this is the screwdriver i will
be giving away this exact one uh it's
one of one in this red and black
colorway i will leave all the bits in it
this is the exact bit i just used to
finish this build and all you have to do
is check the description and that could
be yours that's been my first pc build
in a really long time and i'm glad i did
it
thanks linus
thanks y'all for watching
i'm gonna get back to gaming catch you
guys the next one
peace
[Music]
[Applause]